in this video we're going to get even
more appreciation for why the periodic
table of elements is so useful and in
particular we're going to focus on
groups
of the periodic table of elements when
we talk about a group we're just talking
about a column and as we'll see even
though the elements in a given column
might have very different atomic numbers
they all have similar properties and the
reason why they all have similar
properties is in most cases they have
the same number of valence electrons
remember valence electrons are the
reactive electrons the ones that might
interact with other things and because
elements with similar valence electrons
will have similar reactivities they will
form similar ions
similar
ions
and they will have similar roles similar
roles
in
ionic compounds
ionic compounds
now for the sake of this video i'm going
to focus most on the extremes of the
periodic table the groups at the left
and the right because those are the
closest to having a full outer shell
either by losing electrons or by gaining
electrons so just to remind ourselves
what does it mean to have a full
full
outer shell
well in general people will refer to the
octet rule
for our second third fourth fifth and on
and on shells you're full when you have
eight electrons eight electrons the
major exception to the octet rule is the
first shell whereas it is full with two
electrons so helium either even though
it only has two electrons is very very
very stable and the major data point
that we have around this octet rule are
the group 18 elements right over here
also known as the noble gases they're
known as the noble gases because they're
very unreactive they're very content
they don't want to mess around with
anyone else and that's because all of
the noble gases have full outer shells
helium's outer shell is the first shell
and it's full neon's outer shell is the
second shell it's full our guns out of
shell is the third shell and it's full
and so on and so forth
now if we go one group to the left of
the noble gases we get to the halogens
now the halogens have seven valence
electrons so you can imagine they're
only one electron away from having
electron configuration like the noble
gas to the right of each of them so
these halogens right over here these
really like to attract electrons to form
a negative ion or an anion so you will
often times see
fluorine as a fluoride anion so it has a
negative one charge or you also see
chlorine with a negative one charge as
the chloride anion and i could go on and
on you'll often see iodine gain an
electron and have a negative one charge
if you go one step to the left the
oxygen group oxygen sulfur and on and on
these elements have six valence
electrons so still easier for them to
have a full outer shell by gaining two
electrons than by losing six electrons
so these elements also like to attract
electrons so you can see oxygen as an
oxide anion has gained two electrons it
swiped it from somebody else sulfur as a
sulfide anion
now if you go to the other extreme of
the periodic table if you look at group
one elements they have one valence
electron and especially the ones that
you look in you see in red here which
are known as the alkali metals
it's much easier for them to lose an
electron to have a full outer shell than
for them to gain seven electrons the
reason why hydrogen's a bit of an
exception is it doesn't have to gain
seven electrons to have a full outer
shell it has to gain one so hydrogen
could lose one and essentially have no
electrons or it could gain one electron
and it would have a full outer shell
like helium but when we think about
ionic compounds these alkali metals are
really some of the most interesting
participants because as you can imagine
for them to get stable they they want to
give away an electron so you're very
likely to see them having given away an
electron and having a positive one
charge so you'll oftentimes see a
lithium ion with a positive one charge a
sodium ion with a positive one charge a
potassium ion with a positive one charge
and that's in general true of all of
these group one elements now what about
these group two elements also known as
the alkaline earth metals
well once again it's easier for them to
lose two electrons than for them to gain
six to have a full outer shell so you'll
typically see beryllium having a
positive two charge it would have lost
those two electrons magnesium as having
a positive two charge calcium as having
a positive two charge
now given that how would you expect
things on the left and things on the
right to form ionic compounds so you
might guess if you have an alkali metal
in the presence of a halogen things
could get very reactive in fact things
will get very reactive because these
want to give away electron these want to
take electron and that's what will
happen the electrons will leave the
group one element and then they will go
to the halogen and in the process it
might release a lot of energy but what
you would be left with is an ionic
compound for example lithium loses a
electron
and has a positive one charge that
positive ion would be very attracted to
a chlorine anion that has just gained an
electron maybe it's the same electron or
swipe that electron from another lithium
atom and so these two things would be
attracted and they could form lithium
chloride and all of these alkali metals
could play that same role in this ionic
compound as lithium so it's also typical
to see sodium chloride that is table
salt it's also typical to see potassium
chloride so on and so forth and on the
other hand fluorine or bromine or iodine
can play a similar role as chlorine so
you could see something like sodium
iodide or potassium iodide once again
the alkali metal would have lost an
electron
the halogen would have gained an
electron and then they are attracted to
each other and forming these ionic
compounds
what kind of ionic compounds might be
formed with these group two elements
let's take calcium for example it's not
unreasonable for calcium to lose two
electrons to have a stable outer shell
to have an electron configuration like
argon so if it loses two electrons it
has a positive two charge and you can
imagine those two electrons get lost to
two different iodine
atoms so each of them have a negative
one charge so times two
and then what type of ionic compound
could they form well you could have one
calcium and then two iodines so calcium
iodide is actually an ionic compound you
would see it has a neutral charge
overall because calcium has a positive
two charge and each of the iodines have
a negative one charge but then you have
two of them so it is neutral overall
what might calcium do with oxygen while
calcium likes to lose two electrons
oxygen likes to gain two electrons so
you could see something like calcium
oxide
so i will leave you there the big
picture here is the column in which an
element is tells you a lot about its
reactivity because it tells you in
general how many valence electrons it
has
and
atoms are most stable when they have a
full outer shell and so that helps you
predict hey is it easier for them to
lose electrons and form a positive ion
or gain electrons and form a negative
ion and then from that you can make
predictions as to the types of ionic
compounds that could be formed with the
different elements